hi everyone ted florento here again it's
uh 11 45 i believe i wanted to give you
a quick weather update my colleagues are
on the strip um getting ready to ring in
2022 i'll keep my eye on the winds here
up in the centennial hills right now
because those winds are coming from the
north we're also watching those winds
down the
las vegas strip all the way down to reed
international in the surrounding areas
as well so quick update on those winds
at this time as we're getting getting
closer to midnight we did have a brief
lull a quiet spot or at least calmer
winds after the initial
uh right now those winds are starting to
pick up again uh as that front has
passed through hours ago we're not going
to get those strong winds like we had
earlier that were up to 59 added to reed
international earlier and up to uh high
40s
uh earlier but those winds are picking
up again so i wanted to give you a quick
update so for reed international and the
strip those gusts
we're up to 36 miles per hour but now
i'm seeing them now closer to 40 miles
per hour uh at this hour with sustained
winds at
25 miles per hour so yes it is picking
up again as far as those wind speeds go
spring valley 32 mile per hour southern
highlands 30 mile per hour gusts and all
these are continuing to go up as we
speak right now so i just put these down
and i'm i'm willing to bet the wind
speeds are picking up again all right so
we we talked about earlier that the
county's threshold uh before they were
to light off any fireworks on the las
vegas strip is 10 miles per hour well
we hit 10 miles per hour
a lot
so
it's really going to be up to them and
the national weather service whether the
fireworks do go off we have had those
fireworks go off before in very strong
winds and uh they haven't had an issue
now there is pos there is a chance
victoria saha confirmed this with eric
pappas from the county that if the winds
are too strong for those fireworks to go
off they will delay the fireworks until
1am and check out how those winds will
be then at that time winds will still be
gusty
we're hoping those winds will decrease
more uh at midnight or even obviously
after midnight so again it's not going
to be as strong as we saw earlier but as
you can see there's more
still around we knew there was going to
be an issue no matter what we were going
to have guest you wins this evening even
with the cold front passing through so
that's something that we're watching
right now lydia
um
mary says right they will have the
fireworks with this one it's a tough
call lydia um or obviously mary i
apologize uh but we have seen wind gusts
uh that are behind they have still
lit those fireworks off it's not up to
me of course that is up to the county
they'll decide along with the national
weather service i'm just kind of
relaying the information on the winds
that i am seeing around the region yes
they are picking up again from that
brief what we call
earlier today you can hear it on my
phone here obviously as uh here in
centennial hills those winds are quite
strong because they are coming from the
north now
of course our eight news now team is
getting ready to see what the county
says as far as those fireworks going off
at midnight i'm gonna go run upstairs
here and see if we can catch some of
those fireworks go off they do on time
but i want to give you uh guys all a
quick update and what we heard from the
county in the meantime be safe everyone
and uh have a happy new year and let's
keep your fingers crossed those winds
will go off at midnight
live here in centennials